washington-dc gathers to mourn George HW
Bush 41 we explore Bush 41's a political
legacy and the radical left gains more
steam among the Democratic
intelligentsia i'm ben shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
okay so I do want to get to everything
Bush related I also want to get to
Elizabeth Warren who even the New York
Times is now acknowledging sort of blew
herself up at the behest of President
Trump but we begin today by talking a
little bit about why you should probably
be diversifying have you seen the stock
market this week it is not great
okay the stock market in the last few
days has dumped about 1,500 points so
things are not going to awesome in stock
market well that's because things are
pretty volatile right now there's a lot
of worry about trade wars there's a lot
of worry about the national debt and
that's why you should at least be
diversified should have some of your
money in precious metals can you afford
another hits your retirement like the
last downturn when the S&P dropped 50%
probably not which is why you should at
least have some of your money in
precious metals trust the folks over at
Birch gold group they have thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau it's the holidays you
get gifts for everyone so get yourself a
free gift the gift of understanding how
to diversify by going over to
birchgold.com /ban you get a free
information kit on physical precious
metals see if diversifying into gold and
silver makes some sense for you go check
them out right now it's a comprehensive
16 page kit showing how gold and silver
can protect your savings and how you can
legally move that IRA or 401k out of
stocks and bonds and into a precious
metals IRA if that is something that
you're into to get that no-cost
no-obligation kit go to birchgold.com
slash band that is birchgold.com slash
men go check them out right now
birchgold.com slash veteran okay
yesterday was supposedly a moment of
unity in Washington DC we had all of the
Living X precedents at the National
Cathedral to do a memorial service for
George HW Bush and it really was moving
particularly when people who are close
to George HW Bush folks when George W
Bush spoke for example it was incredibly
moving that however was not the main
headline that came out because that was
never going to be the main headline that
came out whenever there's a political
gathering let's let's face it okay when
there's a memorial like this we all get
together for five minutes and we pretend
that we still have something in common
and it's just like a family reunion at
Christmas or at Hanukkah or at
Thanksgiving you all get together go do
remember we're all family and by halfway
through the meal everybody's throwing
food at each other and trying to Club
each other with the empty bottle of
Martinelli's that's basically how things
are yesterday at the at the National
Cathedral the good part was everything
that genuine friends
family of George HW Bush had to say here
was George W Bush talking about his
father noble and necessary that one can
serve with integrity and hold true to
the important values like faith and
family he strongly believed that it was
important to give back to the community
and country in which one lived he
recognized as serving others enriched
the giver soul to us his was the
brightest of a thousand points of light
in George W Bush talk movingly about his
own relationship with his father all of
which was was good and decent and then
Jon Meacham as a historian got up and
talked about how George HW Bush was a
20th century founding father here's what
he had to say George Herbert Walker Bush
was America's last great soldier
statesman a 20th century founding father
he governed with virtues that most
closely resemble those of Washington and
of Adams of TR and of FDR of Truman and
of eisenhower of men who believed in
causes larger than themselves
okay well the truth is the George HW
Bush was not a visionary right he lacked
what they called the vision thing and in
1992 it came back to bite him he was
much more of a technocrat as we talked
about yesterday on the program he was
much more of a guy who sort of handled
his business and if he'd been president
between 1924 and 1928 for example I
think he would made a fine president his
presidency between 1988 and 1992 was to
put it mildly rather lackluster but the
fact that we see him as a unifying
figure I think says more about where we
are as a country than it does about
George HW Bush the reality is that when
Jon Meacham says whose last soldier
statesman remember John McCain ran for
the presidency in 2008 on a similar war
heroism record on a similarly moderate
record as a legislator and he lost to
Barack Obama a wild leftist day in 2012
a classy middle-of-the-road guy who
and temperament most resembled George HW
Bush lost again to Barack Obama in 1992
George HW Bush bat soldier statesman
lost to a probable rapist so George HW
people decided they weren't interested
in the soldier statesman model and
perhaps that's because we actually have
had a breakdown in the social fabric
when you think about what George HW Bush
represented there's been a lot of talk
about him representing a higher ideals
but the truth is I think what he mostly
represented is she reflected the fact
that we used to have a commonality of
interest and look at the institutions to
which George HW Bush belonged
he was a belong her to the military
obviously was a military hero that was a
unifying institution in American life
Hughes somebody who belonged to the
upper crust of the Ivy League
establishment this was an institution in
American life where a lot of people had
common interests and common values he
was a member of a church he was a
church-going man that that was a
unifying factor in his life all of the
sort of soft things in the background
all of these soft things in the
background that allow us to be a country
together those are what have faded and
that's what we're really mourning when
we mourn George HW Bush's legacy and his
passing is what exactly happened to that
background what happened to the social
fabric that was always the the
background for the tapestry that was
going to be the American story that's
what's missing and the reason I say
that's what's missing is and when
Meacham says that George HW Bush reminds
us of George Washington I think that's
because George HW Bush reminds us of a
time when Americans had a lot more in
common than they do now now what's weird
about that is that we should have more
in common now than we did then obviously
racial conflict in the United States is
on a is thank God on the town where'd
spiral and has been for decades
prosperity in the United States
continues to rise there there are a lot
of reasons why we should be unified but
we are not in fact unified and this goes
back all the way to George Washington's
farewell address you're a 32-page
address to the people of America in
which you weren't against the spirit of
faction he said that that spirit
agitates the community with ill-founded
jealousies and false alarms Kindles the
animosity of one part against another
foments occasionally riot an
insurrection it opens the door to
foreign influence and corruption which
finds facilitate
access to the government itself through
the channels of party passions he talks
about the divisions that the things that
divide us but what is it that will unify
us at George Washington he said in vain
would that man claim the tribute of
patriotism
who should labor to subvert these great
pillars of human happiness these firmest
props of the duties of men and citizens
this would be religion and morality
he says the mere politician equally with
the pious man ought to respect and to
cherish them a volume could not trace
all their connections of private and
public felicity let it simply be asked
where is the security for property for
reputation for life if the sense of
religious obligation desert the oaths
which are the instruments of
Investigation and courts of justice and
let us with caution indulge the
supposition that morality can be
maintained without religion whatever may
be conceded to the influence of refined
education on minds of peculiar structure
reason and experience both forbid us to
expect that national morality can
prevail an exclusion of religious
principle it is substantially true that
virtue or morality is a necessary spring
of popular government the rule indeed
extends more or less force to every
species of free government who that who
that is a sincere friend to it can look
with indifference upon attempts to shake
the foundation of the fabric the
foundation of the fabric has been shaken
when we look at the tributes to George
HW Bush that is the biggest reminder
that is the best reminder is that George
HW Bush reminded us of a time when there
was a common social fabric now there are
a lot of people who'll say yeah but I
wasn't part of that social fabric I was
excluded right and then we made moves to
try and include more people in that
social fabric but at the same time we
decided it was necessary to shred the
social fabric in the name of inclusion
and what that means is that we are now
included in a group in which we have no
commonality and that's what we are all
reminds of and when I look at the the
lineup of presidents were sitting there
President Trump who is for all of the
policies that I like about President
Trump a divisive figure Barack Obama who
is a radical radical leftist with a
corrupt history in Chicago Bill Clinton
who is a corrupt politician through and
through and his wife Hillary Clinton who
ran for president being a very corrupt
politician and what we are looking at is
a country that really has less and less
in common these days well that has led
Ross tout had over at the New York Times
to write a piece talking about why we
miss the wasps and what he's
specifically talking about is what
oklet's in about George HW Bush that we
missed what is his sensibility that we
miss he says the nostalgia flowing since
the passing of George HW Bush has many
Wellsprings admiration for the World War
two generation and it's dying breed of
warrior politicians the usual belated
media affection for moderate Republicans
the contrast between the elder Bush's
foreign policy successes and the
failures of his son and the contrast
between any honorable politician and the
current occupants of the Oval Office but
two of the more critical takes on Bush
nostalgia got closer to the heart of
what was being mourned in distant
hindsight with his death writing in The
Atlantic Peter Beinart who is just an
awful human being described the elder
Bush as the last president deemed
legitimate by both of our country's
warring tribes before the age of
presidential sex scandals plurality
winning in popular vote losing chief
executives and white resentment of the
first black president also in the
atlantic franklin foer described the
subtext of Bush nostalgia as a fondness
for a bygone institution known as the
establishment harden in the cold of New
England Borden's boarding schools
acculturated by the late-night rituals
of skull and bones sent off to the world
with a sense of noblesse oblige
so doubt hat says I think you can
usefully combine these takes and
describe Bush nostalgia as a longing for
something America used to have and
doesn't really anymore a ruling class
that was widely not universally but more
widely than today deemed legitimate and
that inspired various kinds of trusts
intergenerational institutional
conspicuously absent in our society
today put simply Americans miss Bush
because we miss the wasps because we
feel at some level that they're more
meritocratic and diverse and secular
successors rule us neither as wisely
nor as well now I have my disagreements
with this because if you look at the
presidents who we've admired the most
people like Harry Truman to take a
particular example these he was a white
anglo-saxon Protestant but he was
certainly not upper crust and this
feeling like this noblesse oblige
feeling that that dad had his talking
about that this was our our group of
rulers we were going to pick from among
them yeah I think that has its
discontents and certainly it has its
downsides as well I think something else
has happened I don't think that's we
miss the ruling class I think that we
miss the idea that the ruling class in
the United States this sort of
aristocratic tastes at the top of
society that they actually still had a
lot in common with us what's weird is
that as the people who we vote for
become more like us we've seem to have
less in common with the people we vote
for and I think that's
because as a country as a whole we have
less in common with the people around us
we don't know our neighbors we don't
spend any time with them and we don't
aspire to be a George HW Bush we resent
people who make a lot of money we resent
people who are at the top of the
so-called meritocracy I want to talk a
little bit more about that in just a
second first let's talk about something
that you can do for yourself this
holiday season to make yourself look
like a million bucks and that is you can
get a watch folks like that look at this
watch this is a really nice watch how do
I know it's a really nice watch because
I wear it every day it isn't it a
movement watch MVM t.com they've sold
over 2 million watches worldwide and
you'll be sure to find the perfect
holiday gift this season when you head
over to MVM t.com you know I'm all about
supporting ground up entrepreneurs who
work hard for what they want which is
why I love movement so much they're a
true success story
it makes wearing their products that
much more meaningful they came up and
made a name for themselves in one of the
most established markets in the world
they've reached exponential growth
there's a reason for it their product is
really good and they're not gonna give
you watches that tell you eight
different time zones and try and measure
how many steps you take today instead
they just tell you the time in a spare
minimalist classy-looking package
movement watches starts just 95 bucks
you're looking at 400 bucks for the same
quality from a traditional brand not
only do I wear a movement watch shows my
wife so I was my mom so as my father
I've gotten them for a bunch of my
friends as well movement has sold almost
2 million watches in over 160 countries
right now they have awesome gift pockets
boxes and packages for the holiday
season if you need help giving the
perfect gift this Christmas but you
don't know where to start
the guys over at movement watches have
your back they've curated all your
favorite styles into special gift boxes
for you so you can absolutely crush this
holiday season without the added stress
get 15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MVM t-dot-com
slash shapiro movement launching new
styles on their site all the time go
check them out mb mt comm slash up here
to get 15% off today with free shipping
and free returns and they have great
holiday deals right now MVM t-dot-com
slash apparel join the movement go check
them out right now ok so Ross tout how
it basically makes the claim that George
HW Bush was beloved because we accepted
our ruling caste are ruling cased more
bat way back when I don't think that's
right again I think it's that we have
more in common with our ruling caste
than we thought ok one day if I work
hard I can be like those people because
this is a free society and we share the
same values we have all the things in
common that George Washington
talked about in his farewell address but
we don't anymore we don't anymore
here's what doubt hat writes and in
contravention of this idea
he says if some of the elder bushes
mourners wish we still had a wasp
establishment their desired probably
reflects a belated realization that
certain of the old establishments vices
were inherent to any elite the merit of
meritocracy creates its own forms of
exclusion and that the wasps had virtues
that their successors have failed to
inherit or revive those virtues included
a spirit of noblesse oblige and personal
austerity and piety that went beyond the
thank you notes and boat shoes in prep
school Chapel going a spirit to train
the most privileged children for service
not just success that sent men like
bushing to combat alongside the sons of
farmers and mechanics in the same way
that it sent missionaries and diplomats
abroad in the service of their churches
and their countries so he sort of trucks
this up to wasp habits what I would say
is that these used to be much more
universal values and they also applied
to the people who ruled the country and
now they're not universal values and
they apply to no one and so our last
several presidents have had significant
moral failings have real significant
moral failings and the one who is
probably the best man among them george
w bush was excoriated as war monger by
everybody else and well none of this
really all the feel-good ism didn't
really hold up to scrutiny for very long
because as it turns out we are still an
extraordinarily divided nation and as
you know I'm not ripping on displays of
patriotic unity I think that sometimes
those are necessary but it is hard not
to look at the display yesterday in
which you had presidents from sitting
next to Melania sitting next to the
Obamas the Obamas despised the Trump's
and probably vice versa and then you
have the Obamas sitting next to the
Clintons the Obamas despise the Clintons
and the Clintons despise the Trump's and
they all despise each other and not
think to yourself maybe we as a country
of law something right and I'm not
that's not a rip on Trump specifically
or even Obama specifically or even
Clinton specifically although I have
serious problems with all of the
aforementioned it does raise questions
as to what we as a country have in
common when our leadership has virtually
nothing in common with each other and
you can see that in some of the video
from yesterday so some of the video from
yesterday that was going viral was
Hillary Clinton purportedly snubbing the
Trump's and you can see the media trying
to gin this up I am unclear as to
whether Hillary Clinton is actually
sport spurning Melania Trump here it
would not be supremely
prising it she war but I think it's a
tape that can be read both ways what
certainly cannot be read both ways to
the media coverage of it so here what
here's what it looked like when Donald
Trump and Melania Trump sat down next to
the Obamas and the Clintons so what you
will see is Melania and Trump they're
shaking hands with people and Trump
reaches over he shakes hands with
Michelle Obama and then the cleanse is
sort of look away from Clinton's did not
acknowledge president Trump so obviously
the media very ends the idea that all
these people hate each other because the
truth is we all know deep down they
really do hate each other but you know
what the media hates most of all what
the media hates most of all are the
Trump's so MSNBC went nuts over Trump
now at Trump's behavior at the funeral
was nothing right I mean like he didn't
do anything wrong at this memorial
service
Trump's behavior at the memorial service
was perfectly normal that didn't stop
the media from losing its ever-loving
mind over his presence at the funeral
what I love is all of the people in the
media saying well Trump ripped on george
w bush and he ripped on jeb bush and he
was mean to them so you shouldn't have
shown up does anyone remember Barack
Obama calling george w bush a war
criminal in essence and he did it a lot
does anybody remember Bill Clinton going
after George HW Bush in 1992 excoriating
him trying to destroy him does anybody
remember any of this politics is
partisan game but the media were very
upset that Trump would even be in the
same vicinity as an event that people
have emotional attachment to so here is
MSNBC going nuts over President Trump
there has not been an example since he
emerged on the political stage of him
being able to see anything as not about
him this was a service it was not about
him and the premise of being invited was
that at least for maybe two hours you'd
stop all this and it's not about you and
Ray take it and it really wasn't about
him I mean it is all he could do was sit
there and the rest of the program went
on okay the the so MSNBC is very upset
that Trump did not make it about himself
but it was still all about him okay Don
Lemon was even worse he says that that
Trump should not have even shown up to
the funeral after talking smack about
george w bush again
the great meeting of the mental
luminaries Don Lemon and Chris Cuomo on
CNN discuss I don't think that's respect
for the human being if you talk smack
about them if you say the nastiest
things about them if you treat them as
subhuman
and then you want to show up at their
funeral really well I'll tell you first
of all the Bush's invited President
Trump right John McCain's is Senator
McCain's family didn't invite president
Trump's of President Trump didn't show
up the Bush family invited President
Trump and wanted him there specifically
for the show of unity but it doesn't
matter Trump can obey the wishes of the
Trump of the Bush family and he still
will get ripped up and down the
Washington Post's coverage of this was
particularly absurd they have a piece by
Greg Jaffe today that says at George HW
Bush's funeral a magisterial presidency
meets one diminished by division are we
gonna pretend that George HW Bush's
presidency wasn't diminished by division
that his presidency was purely
Magisterial were gonna do now he served
one term and then he lost because a
third party candidate won 19% of the
vote but apparently you know every every
opportunity to use George Bush to
contrast a trump as opposed to
contrasting what the country was in 1990
and maybe before with the with the
spirit of America now know it's all
gonna be about Trump Greg Jaffe at the
Washington Post writing the man the men
who came to eulogize former President
George HW Bush spoke of the 41st
presidents in the American presidency on
Wednesday in broad and Magisterial terms
but the words of praise for Bush seem to
contrast for the jarring reality a
generation after he left office the
presidency has become all-consuming in
American life yet it has also never
seemed smaller and more prone to failure
I don't think they'll be writing the
same thing about Barack Obama who
militarized the executive branch against
his political enemies that wasn't the
only article on the front page of the
Washington Post website then another
article that said Bush funeral Trump
sits with fellow presidents but still
stands alone this one from Philip Rucker
from the moment he crossed the transept
of the store in Washington National
Cathedral tore off his overcoat and took
his seat in the front pew President
Trump was an outsider when the other
sang an opening hymn his mouth did not
move when the others read the Apostles
Creed he stood stoic Lee and when one
you were just after another testified to
George HW Bush's integrity and character
and honesty and bravery and compassion
Trump sat and listened often with his
lips pursed and his arms crossed over
his chest
so now we're doing body language
breakdowns President Trump at a funeral
for national unity mm-hmm well done
Washington Post really good stuff also I
do love there a lot of people very upset
that President Trump and Melania didn't
say the Apostles Creed and while other
people said the Apostles Creed are we
supposed to pretend that Bill Clinton
saying the Apostles Creed makes him a
saint but suddenly Bill Clinton gets
canonized because he was saying the
Apostles Creed he's a true Christian
Bill Clinton you know and he's not
stopping everything in sight with or
without consent we're supposed to
pretend that that is just a sign of
decency now the Washington Post
continues Wednesday state funeral was
carefully orchestrated to be about one
man and his milestones Bush the father
the friend the war hero but inevitably
became about Trump too far was
impossible to pay tribute to the 41st
president without drawing implicit
contrast with the 45th I've been saying
this for days that the reason the media
are doing a lot of the over-the-top
hagiography of George HW Bush is
specifically in order to tear down
President Trump that was pretty obvious
from the outset look you again you can
look at George HW Bush and miss maybe a
time when Americans valued statesmanship
but let's not pretend that the end of
statesmanship began with President Trump
because that is a bunch of nonsense and
we all know it we all know it and in a
second I want to talk a little bit about
George HW Bush's sort of reactions a
president Trump and I also want to talk
about the Democrats preparing for 2020
but first let's talk about how you cook
your dinner with the holidays fast
approaching meal prep is the last thing
you want on your plate you don't want to
be schlepping on over to the grocery
store trying to figure out a recipe
buying too much of the ingredients
coming home making a giant mess what if
cooking delicious wholesome meals is
actually easy well it can be with blue
apron folks around the office been using
blue apron for months and they say that
it is fantastic it's such a great idea I
mean having these prepackaged meals
essentially made before you make them
for yourself right all the ingredients
come prepackaged the freshest
ingredients the best ingredients and the
best recipes and you're cooking like the
gourmet in your own home it's pretty
amazing blue apron really gives everyone
a better way to cook they take the chore
out of meal prep and they give you
creative and mouth-watering options that
fit your taste check out this week's
menu get your first three meals for free
at blue aprons comm slash up here these
are meals we're sharing on social media
in as little as 20 minutes it's blue
apron slash appear I'm looking at some
of these meals right now this is the
stuff you could be making
seared steaks and loaded mashed potatoes
panko crusted chicken and maple dipping
sauce creamy saffron risotto I mean this
is solid solid stuff newbie making this
in your own home yourself like a gourmet
blue apron calm / appear to get your
first three meals for free blue apron is
indeed a better way to cook go check
them out right now okay so well this
morning for George HW Bush goes on and
while we contrast the era of George HW
Bush and maybe the social fabric of
George HW Bush with today's social
fabric it is important to note as I said
yesterday that George HW Bush and the
establishment Republicans disdain for
people who are not of the elite did
breed a backlash so here's what rot down
hat is right over at over at the New
York Times when he says that there's a
nostalgia for a sort of aristocracy in
the United States let's not pretend that
that did not create a backlash it
absolutely did one of the things that
always used to make me a little sick to
my stomach was watching as the Bush
family embraced the Clinton family I
never understood it it made no sense to
me these were not people who shared
values these were not people who shared
a vision for the country and if they
embraced each other because they felt
that they had something else in common
I'm wondering what exactly that was I
always felt like you know a fan of the
Boston Red Sox and New York Yankees and
then you find and you're rooting for
your team to beat the other team then
you find out that the players in the
offseason are best friends and go
fishing together and you think to
yourself wait a second aren't they
supposed to you know be fighting against
each other
that doesn't mean they should be beating
each other's brains in but these sort of
warmth that Bush showed toward showed
toward the Clintons the Bush family
showed toward the Clintons was always
off-putting to a lot of people who felt
like this was more of an evidence of a
of a of an inborn elite who had decided
to associate with each other than people
who were really unified with the
American people per se so when Maureen
Dowd says that George HW Bush cursed
about Trump and threw his shoe at the TV
whenever he appeared you know that
creates a rather large backlash against
exactly the sort of aristocracy that
Ross dude had is talking about
HW was talking about how much he liked
Bill Clinton and Obama and I said what
do you think of this Trump birther thing
and he just said you know in essence
he's a jerk with a different word and
but I just I think III heard later that
he was throwing a shoe at the television
set when Trump came on and this is why
the media of course are doing a
geography of of George HW Bush because
this is this is what they want they want
this division now again we are going to
have to rebuild the social fabric from
the ground up but that's not gonna
happen anytime soon not with the
politics that we currently have the
latest evidence of this comes courtesy
of Elizabeth Warren so this is just too
funny do you remember a few weeks back
is mending mid-october Elizabeth Warren
decided that it was imperative that she
released a DNA test demonstrating her
Native American bona fide ease because
many people had said lady you are whiter
than the backside of this sheet of paper
right here I mean you are as white as
the driven snow and Elizabeth Warren
said no I have high cheekbones I'm
Native American and then she went she
got like a genetic test a DNA test and
it turned out she was maybe one 1024
Native American and the media celebrated
this we read the headlines at the time
the media said she has been vindicated
she's a Native American how dare you
question her ancestry well the rest of
us were like ah that's not what the test
showed and also what well now it turns
out that we won the argument right those
of us who actually have any tenuous
relationship with reality we won this
particular argument because now the New
York Times is reporting that one time
Democratic 2020 presidential frontrunner
senator Elizabeth Warren has fallen on
hard times politically why because of
that DNA test
so trumped role turned to taking a DNA
test and now she's got problems quote
from the New York Times nearly two
months after Miss Warren released the
test results and drew hostile reactions
from prominent tribal leaders the linger
and cloud over her likely presidential
campaign has only darkened conservatives
who continue to ridicule her more
worrisome to supporters of Miss Warren's
presidential ambitions she has yet to
allay criticism from grassroots
progressive groups liberal political
operatives and other potential 2020
allies who complain that she put too
much emphasis on the controversial field
of racial science and in doing so played
into mr. Trump's hands so she tried to
break into the intersectional group by
releasing a DNA test and everybody's
like nah lady you're white not allowed
so it's it's it's really fun to watch
all of these upper crust white
candidates try to break into the
intersectional battleground that the
Democratic Party has become I'm the one
N you have somebody like Kirsten
and another rich white lady who tweets
out our future is female intersectional
powered by our belief in one another and
we're just getting started
as my as my friend and business partner
Jeremy boring says I'm not sure why
she's allowed to assume the gender of
the future that said that seems
transphobic but in any case Warren went
even further an attempt to prove she
could compete with all the other
minority candidates she didn't just pay
tribute intersectionality she tried to
become part of the intersectional
coalition and she looked really bad
doing it and now the New York Times is
recognizing this so how is the
Democratic Party breaking down for 2020
well they've got the intersectional
radicals then they've got the
establishment Ariens and then they have
the Bernie Sanders radicals and this
means that if you had to name the people
who are the top candidates right now it
would be from the establishment Joe
Biden from the intersectional side
Kamala Harris and from the Sanders bro
flavor of the month
that'd be beta O'Rourke so those would
be your top three candidates if you had
to handicap this race right now all
three of them are increasingly radical
and Elizabeth Warren was not radical
enough she tried to break from the
Sanders bro area of the Democratic Party
into the intersectional area of the
party and she failed dramatically
because as it turns out there are
serious gaps between these three
sections of the party if you are a
Democrat and these gaps are only going
to get larger as the Democratic Party
becomes more and more radical on a wide
variety of issues take for example the
issue of intersex intersectionality so
intersectionality now demands that we
ignore anti-semitism in favor of more
put upon intersectional groups we've
talked about this in the past that
intersectionality for those who don't
know is a theory that says that
everybody's experience is defined by
their group identity so if you are a
black person you have a different
experience in America than a white
person if you're a black woman you're a
member of two intersectional groups and
those overlapping experiences those
intersecting experiences define your
life in America and we can determine how
seriously to take your opinion or how
victimized you have been which are flip
sides of the same coin and leftism by
how many intersectional groups you
belong to and when it comes to this
intersectional hierarchy we rank various
groups by level of victimization in
American society Jews because they are
economically successful in the United
States rank very low on the
intersectional hierarchy so the left has
decided that anti-semitism is no longer
a problem they are not going to focus in
on Syria Santa
unless they can shout about
anti-semitism in order to bash President
Trump like they did after the Pittsburgh
white supremacist shooting
thus you now have several members of the
Democratic caucus who've come out in
favor of the openly anti-semitic
proposal to boycott divest and sanction
the State of Israel for building extra
bathrooms in East Jerusalem and they're
still willing to hobnob with folks like
Mark Lamont Hill mark Lamont Hill
recently fired from CNN after going to
the UN and shouting the Hamas slogan
from the river to the sea Palestine
shall be free well it turns out that
just a few months ago nobody cared about
this back a few months ago September
2018 mark Lamont Hill suggested that the
Jews were poisoning the water of the
Palestinians okay that's called the
blood libel for those who don't know any
Jewish history hey back during the
Crusades there were suggestions lies is
bacne eleventh and twelfth centuries
there were lies that Jews have been
poisoning the wells of Christians in
order to kill them okay and this was
called the blood libel because then this
would result in pogroms here is Mark
Lamont Hill engaging in an actual blood
libel and nobody cared at all and in the
Democratic Party this guy is still
considered you know in an intellectual
of sort
how can you romanticize non-violence
when you have a state that is at all
moments waging war against you against
your bodies poisoning your water
limiting your access to water locking up
your children killing you we can't
romanticize resistance poisoning your
water poisoning your water yes he gets
away with that no problem at all and on
the intersectionality side of the
Democratic Party it gets even more
radical when we get to gender and then
wait until we get to sort of the Bernie
Sanders side of the party which is
becoming more radical as well so for all
the Democrats you think they're going to
just walk over President Trump in 2020
all I would say is look to your own
house first guys we'll get to all that
in just a second first let's talk about
your second Amendment rights you're a
gun lover and you're running out of time
why because you could hit the range
tomorrow with a brand new gun I know
that I would love to do so and the US
ECI wants to make that dream come true
for you right now they're here to help
train and protect responsible gun owners
like you and me and right now they're
giving away free guns every day so you
have to check them out they're giving
you up to 24 chances to win a different
gun every single day but it all ends
soon just text safe to the number 8 7 2
2 2 and get entered right now you could
get up to 24 chances to win your gun
daily it could be 24 kembers don't
Glocks 24 new cigs all you have to do is
text the word safe SAF e2 8 7 2 2 2 and
reveal which gun you could be taking
home today but this all ends soon
today's gun disappears at midnight
tonight these guys are doing some really
great things they provide you all sorts
of services other than the ability to
win a free gun all you have to do right
now is you get yourself involved it's
text safe to eight seven two two to get
your free entry to win that's safe -
eight seven two two - there are folks
who provide you the legal assistance
necessary if God forbid you actually
have to fight or a gun at somebody they
give you all the educational background
that you need they give you all sorts of
other services and again you could win a
new gun today just by texting safe -
eight seven - - to go do it right now
the us CCA
making the lives of gun owners in
America better every day tech safe -
eight seven - - - go check that out
right now also make sure that you go
subscribe over at Sayle wire.com for
$9.99 a month you can get the rest of
the show live you can also get the rest
of Michael Moses show live Andrew Klavan
show live you get all of these wonders
when you subscribe Plus coming January
if you subscribe to get two extra hours
of me a day so you think that I've raced
through the news and lightning pace on
this podcast wait until I actually have
the ability to expand on my thoughts in
a full three-hour format because that's
what begins in January go check it out
right now over at daily wire for $99 you
get that all of that Plus this the very
greatest and beverage vessels we are on
the road and as you know our magical
leftist tiers hot or cold tumbler has an
invisibility a cloaking device and I
just hit the button and it disappears
when I get back to Los Angeles I will
automatically and it will automatically
reappear it I can't say it works for
everyone I can't I can't promise you
that if you get a tumblr that that will
actually be one of the features of the
tumblr I can say that it may or may not
be true in any case go check that out
you get all of those things and
subscribe over at YouTube or iTunes
leave us a review we really appreciate
it we were one of the top 10 downloaded
podcasts in America according to iTunes
for the year 2018 thank you so much for
doing that for us tell all your friends
to subscribe so we can continue that
growth trajectory leading up to 2020 go
check us out right now we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so the intersectional apps growing
increasingly radical Elizabeth were not
radical enough for them in fact
insulting to them Elizabeth Warren it's
really insulting to them speaking by the
way of the intersectional left it'll be
amazing to watch as the bad behavior of
particular candidates who please the
intersectional left are completely
overlooked so I will take for example
Kamala Harris who I mentioned before as
a possible tier 1 candidate for the
Democrats in 2020 what makes her it's
your own one candidate well she's a
senator from California
and she's a woman and she's black that's
pretty much it those are the things
because she doesn't have a legislative
record she was not a good Attorney
General in the state of California I was
there I remember she does not do
anything of note except for tell lies
about Brett Kavanaugh apparently in
judicial hearings but this is made her a
front-runner because something okay but
she's such a promoter she's so high on
the intersectionality scale that she can
get away with ignoring the fact that a
long time top staffer of hers just had
to pay out four hundred thousand dollars
in a harassment and retaliation
settlement and she didn't do anything
about it is according to the Sacramento
Bee today a longtime top staffer of US
Senator Kamala Harris resigned on
Wednesday after the Sacramento Bee
inquired about a four hundred thousand
dollar harassment and retaliation
settlement resulting from his time
working for Harris at the California
Department of Justice Larry Wallace who
served as the director of the division
of law enforcement under then attorney
general Harris was accused by his former
executive assistant since December 2016
of gender harassment and other demeaning
behavior including frequently asking her
to crawl under his desk to change the
paper in his printer the lawsuit was
filed December 30th 2016 when Harris was
still Attorney General but prepping to
be sworn in as the Democratic senator it
was settled less than five months later
in May 17 by Xavier by Xavier Becerra
who's appointed to replace her as
Attorney General
by that time Wallace had transitioned to
work for Harris as a senior advisor in
her Sacramento office we were unaware of
this issue and take accusations of
harassment extremely seriously this
evening mr. Wallace offered his
resignation to the senator and she
accepted it
Harris spokeswoman Lily Adams wrote an
email I love this Harris who said she
will decide over the holidays whether to
run for president in 2020 has been a
prominent figure in the me2 movement so
in other words she knew this for years
and she didn't care for years until the
Sacramento Bee asked her about it how do
we know she didn't care because she
I'm alone when she moved to the Senators
office right so sexual hurry don't worry
they'll they'll cover up for Kamala
Harris there's no way they're gonna let
Kamala Harris go down on something like
this the same thing is true of folks on
the Left who are I mean it's not just
her there's a story out of New Jersey
today that's astonishing about the New
Jersey Governor who the governor Murphy
a governor Murphy is a is a new
democratic hero governor Murphy but it's
okay because he's Democratic hero for
him to have overlooked allegations of
sexual assault in his administration
this is according into this is according
to Andrew Seidman over the over at the
Philadelphia Inquirer and official in
the Murphy administration describes in
harrowing terms Tuesday how high-ranking
members of Governor Murphy's campaign
and staff including the governor himself
failed to act when she tried to alert
them about a campaign aide who's who she
says raped her I had access to people in
the highest positions of power in the
state of New Jersey Katie Brennan chief
of staff for the state's housing agency
testified during a legislative hearing
at each turn my pleas for help went
unanswered somehow it wasn't a priority
to address my sexual assault and working
with my rapist until it impacted them so
she testified about all of this this is
the first major scandal for Murphy for
governor Murphy but is it going to take
him out of course not of course it's not
gonna take him down he's a Democrat
let's not be silly
okay the current senator from the state
of New Jersey was embroiled in sexual
allegations about underage prostitutes
in Puerto Rico and is still or in the
Dominican Republic rather and is still
doing just fine right so New Jersey
Governor Phil Murphy will survive all of
this and continue to be a democratic
star because Democratic priorities Trump
all else
so the intersectional nonsense that the
Democratic Party continues to embrace
will continue to unfold before us in
real time ignoring all of the downside
speaking of intersectional nonsense
today the American Association of
University Professors which is this -
group of University Professors they've
decided that there are not two sexes
there they're no longer two sexes so
intersectionality picking up steam as we
go on it's not just intersectionality
intersectional wings of the Democratic
Party that are moving far to the left it
is the economic wings of the Democratic
Party that are also moving increasingly
far to the left their latest Bugaboo the
thing that they are going
use to scare everybody into giving them
control of the economy is of course
global warming global warming it they've
decided that now global warming there
they can come out of the closet now
global warming is going to be the tool
that they use for global redistribution
ISM despite the fact by the way that the
United States is the number one carbon
emissions reducer this year on planet
Earth and the fact that global carbon
emissions continue to increase
thanks to countries that are signatories
to the Paris Accords this is according
to the Washington Post today global
emissions of carbon dioxide are reaching
the highest levels on record
scientists projected on Wednesday in the
latest evidence of the chasm between
international goals for combating
climate change and what countries are
doing between 2014 and 2016 emissions
remain largely flat leading to hopes
that the world was beginning to turn a
corner those hopes appear to have been
dashed in 2017 global emissions grew 1.6
percent the rise in 2018 is projected to
be 2.7 percent why well let's see it
says the unmitigated growth of carbon
emissions four point seven percent
increase thanks to China the United
States basically kept level with its
prior with its prior increases EU
dropped India increased by six point
three percent the expected increase is
being driven by nearly five percent
growth of emissions in China and more
than six percent in India as nations
continue climate talks in Poland the
message Wednesdays report was
unambiguous when it comes to promises to
begin cutting greenhouse gas emissions
that fuel climate change the world is
well off target but this makes Democrats
happy because this gives them an excuse
the Bernie bros it gives them an excuse
to push for vast redistribution of
wealth and of course the person leading
that charge in terms of vast
distribution of wealth Alexandre Ocasio
cortes now again I don't mean to pick on
Alexander Ocasio Cortez she just says
dumb stuff a lot it is also true that if
were Alexandra Acacio Cortez an actual
presidential candidate there's a good
shot that should wipe out everybody else
in the Democratic Party in the primaries
I kid you not a first a first term
Congress person she could easily I mean
Barack Obama was in Congress for five
seconds before he ran for president if
Alexander Ocasio Cortes were to run for
president I mean she can she's
ineligible she's too young
if she were old enough to run for
president she would do serious damage on
the Democratic side
because she spans two of the groups so
again there are three groups in the
Democratic Party the establishment the
Bernie bros and the intersectional group
she spans the intersectional group and
the Bernie bros and she knows how to pay
homage to the to the establishment group
you have to have two of those groups in
order to win a primary there very few of
these candidates who do well Alexandra
Ocasio cortez using the climate change
issue as a baton to wield against the
United States economy here she is
explaining that climate change is going
to establish economic justice across the
world meaning redistribution ISM it's
not just possible that we will create
jobs and economic activity by
transitioning to renewable energy but
it's inevitable that we are gonna create
jobs it's inevitable that we're gonna
create industry and it's inevitable that
we can use the transition to a hundred
percent renewable energy as the vehicle
to truly deliver and establish economic
social and racial justice in the United
States of America I mean that is sure
nonsense what she is saying there she's
saying basically that if you cram down
enormous amounts of regulation and
destroy the carbon basis for the economy
which is particularly effective for poor
people that this will somehow establish
economic and racial justice really
they're trying that in France right now
you know what it resulted in massive
riots in the streets and the government
of France backing off their own carbon
tax
so no none of that is true but she's
saying the stuff that is necessary
inside the Democratic Party so the great
hope for the Republicans is not the
throat that President Trump
somehow pulls a rabbit out of the Hat
again in 2020 the great hope for the
Republicans is that the divisions in the
Democratic Party continue to widen the
divisions between the intersectional
side and the progressive side and that
both of those sides continue to double
down on the stupid that both of those
sides continue to grow more and more
radical that the intersectional politics
of the Left causes them to savage each
other which intersectionality inherently
does and that the progressive side the
Bernie Sanders side continues to embrace
more and more socialistic policies
including massive crackdowns on the US
economy
it was amazing Bernie Sanders is
tweeting out the other day that Europe
has gotten their emissions under control
why can't we do the same okay so what
carbon tax rate would Bernie Sanders
prefer it's always amazing you never
hear anybody on the Left actually talk
about the tax rates in Europe which are
exorbitant we talked about it the other
day the tax on
ezal fuel in France is 60% the tax on
unleaded gas in in France is over 60%
there's not a country in the EU that has
taxes on unleaded fuel below 50% you
think that will work out well you try
that in the United States it's real easy
for all these folks to say this when we
are the biggest booming economy in the
history of the world what happens when
the United States economy drops do you
think that Europe's gonna be able to
continue to grow economically if the
u.s. destroys its own economy on the
shoals of this environmental
redistributionist nonsense of course not
of course not but Democrats will
continue to promote it because they have
lied to their base about the impacts of
all of their proposed policies now
speaking of Liars this is an amazing
story lena dunham was the creator of
girls and just an awful person she
claimed she had inside information in
November 2017 exonerating a writer named
marie miller from claims by actress
Aurora Parra know that he had sexually
assaulted her in 2012 and she was 17
well it turns out that she lied so she
issued a statement in 2017 she said
during the windfall of deeply necessary
accusations over the last few months in
Hollywood we've been thrilled to see so
many women's voices heard and dark
experiences in this industry justified
it's a hugely important time of change
in like every feminist in Hollywood and
beyond we celebrate we believe having
worked closely closely with Marie Miller
that he has been the wrong target while
our first instinct is to listen to every
woman's story our insider knowledge of
Marie situation makes us confident that
sadly this accusation is one of the 3%
of assault cases that are Mis reported
every year but on Wednesday writing in
The Hollywood Reporter lena dunham
offered an apology to paranoia beginning
by celebrating the past year for
unprecedented dialogue about issues like
wage equality and systemic bias and most
notably sexually assault and harassment
but then she got to the issue said so
many of us have spent such a long time
hiding our trauma at least I know I had
and I walked around feeling like such a
victim and she talked about how tough
she's had issues I never stopped much
less stopped to consider that I might be
capable of traumatizing somebody too and
so I made a terrible mistake when
someone I knew someone I had loved his
brother was accused I did something
inexcusable I publicly spoke up in his
defense there are a few acts I could
ever regret more in this life I did not
have the insider information I claimed
but rather blind faith in a story they
kept slipping and changing and revealed
itself to me nothing at all so lena
dunham lie
about having insider information
exonerating a friend of hers in the me2
movement which again goes to show you
that so many of these movements can be
easily politicized for personal gain it
is astonishing it is astonishing okay in
just a second let's get some things I
like and then some things I hate so
let's do a thing that I like the thing
that I like today so I had a plane ride
yesterday the thing that I hate is that
this plane ride had no internet but you
are able to at least download the United
app and that meant that you could watch
a certain number of movies well I'd seen
a lot of the movies that were there I
had not seen Borg versus McEnroe I am a
tennis fan and this movie is really
quite good
Shia LaBeouf basically plays child above
actual cannibal Shia LaBeouf he actually
plays Shia LaBeouf and he stars as John
McEnroe and the guy whose name I'm gonna
mispronounce dramatically here is very
good Nansen he not even close he plays
Bjorn Borg the movie is really
first-rate here's a little bit of the
trailer it's the perfect rivalry the
baseline player and the net Russia
[Music]
so a lot of the movies in Swedish
obviously do support northern Sweden
[Music]
no special feelings just funny brother
the only thing standing between Borg and
that record is you
[Music]
if the movie is really worth watching if
you're a tennis fan if your sports fan
and it's good drama it's well-acted
LaBeouf is really first-rate net he's
actually a really good actor he's a
talented guy Shia LaBeouf it's too bad
the guy has such issues because if he
could control himself he'd really be a
bigger star than he is as opposed to
making headlines for whatever is his
latest dick okay so time for another
thing that I let's see is there anything
else that I'd like today now see some
stuff that I hate so things that I hate
okay thing that I hate number one so
California is now looking to mandate
solar power for new homes according to
the Orange County Register California
officially became the first state in the
nation on Wednesday to require homes
built in 2020 and later be solar powered
so a smattering of applause the
California Building Standards Commission
voted unanimously to add energy
standards approved last made by another
panel to the State Building Code to
commissioners and several public
speakers allowed at the new code as a
historic undertaking and a model for the
nation the new provisions are expected
to dramatically boost the number of
rooftop solar panels in the Golden State
last year buyers took out permits for
more than one that 115,000 new homes
almost half of them for single-family
homes why do I hate this not because I
hate solar energy I'm fine with solar
energy I hate this because inevitably
this is going to increase real estate
prices because now it costs more to
build a home when the cost goes up that
cost is passed on to the consumer or
theoretically it will be the state of
California paying for the subsidy for
all of this
which means raising taxes in the state
of California yet again the state of
California is already running massive
massive hundreds of billions of dollars
of debt and the idea trillions of
dollars of debt if you count their
unfunded liabilities and if you look and
all of that combined with the tax rates
in California which are the highest in
the nation let's just add some a
regulation on top of that and increase
real estate prices in the middle of a
real estate shortage it makes perfect
sense to me just genius stuff happening
in California every single day when
there no consequences to your activity
because people in California vote
basically straight-line Democrat no
matter what then you can do presumably
whatever you want okay other things that
I hate so there's a story over at
BuzzFeed news today about Neil deGrasse
Tyson this is really starting gaining
steam now and it's amazing Neil deGrasse
Tyson has had a bevy of allegations now
come
against him about sexual harassment and
1/k sexual assault there was a claim by
a woman that way back when they were at
University of Texas at Austin together
that he sexually assaulted her they
raped her that allegation came out a
couple of years ago and didn't make a
lot of lives but now there are a bunch
of other women who are coming forward
and saying that they have been sexually
harassed or abused by by neil degrasse
tyson apparently there was an assistant
named Ashley Watson who was ecstatic
earlier this year when she got a job to
be neil degrasse tyson's driver she
wanted to be a Hollywood producer and
thought the gig with his hit TV show
cosmos could help make her useful
industry connections and then she was
driving him around at one point and
apparently he invited her up to his
apartment to unwind over a bottle of
wine she felt uncomfortable as he gazed
into her eyes and held her wrist to feel
her spirit connection which is as a move
I guess they spent two hours together as
he made sexual references to song lyrics
and describes his need for physical
release as she was leaving he took her
by the shoulders and said I want to hug
you so bad right now but I know that if
I do I'll just want more so she went to
the wine producer and reported the
incident and she resigned and the line
producer said that everybody should tell
everybody she was leaving due to a
family emergency so that was another
story and then there's the rape story
there's a third story where apparently
he was at a party with this woman who
had a tattoo of the solar system which
is a weird thing to do and he asked if
he could see Pluto and then tried to
look down her shirt apparently in front
of other people this is the allegation
and now there is a fourth allegation of
of something similar
the fourth allegation essentially states
that that he came on to her at a museum
holiday party she says that they were at
this Museum holiday party and he started
hitting on her and he tried to touch her
or something in any case none of this
none of this is great stuff for neil
degrasse tyson and just shows you that
powerful men in positions of power you
know they really have to number one they
should be careful number two they should
be moral and number three depending on
which side of the political aisle you're
on you can survive any amounts of this
so again if this had been a claim that
was made
about anybody on the right I highly
doubt that everybody would been treating
the claims with with quite such
skepticism considering how they treated
unverified and unverifiable claims
against Brett Kavanaugh so that's that
all right so we will be back here
tomorrow we'll be back in our normal
studios we will have reactivated our
leftist here's how to rekall tumblr so
you'll be able to physically see it but
until then keep keep your head down have
a nice day
and we'll see you here tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing